last time I was here guys
I may have gone on a little rant about
your bicyclists
you guys have the most
arrogant
bicyclists I have ever [ __ ]
[ __ ] those [ __ ] [ __ ] them [ __ ] [ __ ]
those bucks I'm in an Uber and I said
there's a bicyclist doing 20 in front of
us turn to the guy I'm like
and he just goes
[Applause]
you gonna honk at him
he's gonna be mad
[Applause]
but I'm like huh I'll handle with
whatever happens right he just gives
this dude
my man on his [ __ ] my you know
on his bicycle goes just like this
[Applause]
oh yeah
he [ __ ] comes back anymore
wraps on the window on my feet
watch out for bike
and I go hey first of all bro
[Music]
you're not a biker
[Applause]
you're invest in a [ __ ] teardrop
tattoo because they killed somebody
[Applause]
you can spandex shorts in a [ __ ] kale
smoothie get the [ __ ] away
I want you to know that they reached out
to me
yeah just in the way I thought they
would
I want to tell you two specific
responses that I got that
could not have been better
so one was just a picture of a dude and
he was wearing his bike outfit you know
you know
and he had his his you know his Cosby
sweater but spandex style you know that
multi-colored you know it's by the way I
said Cosby and you were all like is this
a rape joke no it's a [ __ ] sweater
joke everybody
all right everybody's [ __ ] just need
to
so
dude sitting here he's got his bike and
he's [ __ ] like flexing like aggro and
he's he's taking a picture like this in
his bike outfit next to his bike
and it just said if you see me coming in
Portland you better go the other way
[Applause]
I'll be in a car you should go the other
way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what I'm saying
[Applause]
like and then this dude this [ __ ] guy
he
this other guy sent me a message he just
said if you crashed in your car I
wouldn't pull over to help you on my
bike and I was like
first of all if I crash in my car man
what what are you
where you got some gauze in your fanny
pack Joseph like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do for me
you're gonna prop my head up with your
Helm or your shark helmets what are you
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air